a good 13 years of my life was here in
America trying to make a life for me and
my wife
at the time gaming wasn't exploding like
how it is now so she couldn't see the
light at the end of the tunnel
I don't hate her or anything like that I
understand she wanted to make sure she
secured a life for herself make sure she
had a family so she couldn't take that
ride with me
in Jamaica they tell you when you're
growing up that in America the roads are
paved in gold one time I found a hundred
dollar bill in my life walking and
anyone who's watching this I'm sure you
found a 20 or 10 $100 bill on a street
in Jamaica that's not possible
in Jamaica everyone watches their money
there's no points to be found in the
street no nothing so for my parents I
came to New York
well my father first came to this
country with my mother dairy separated
my mother went back to Jamaica and my
father was left here with me or my two
brothers
he drove a taxi 18 hours a day he took
up a job at the Wayne really worked from
inventory to manager to executive
manager to junior or senior executive
and he did that for like 16 years
14-hour shifts until his entire body
broke down on him failed it and now you
can't work anymore everybody starts at
the ground level the suckers are always
at the bottom and they stay at the
bottom
it's like playing a video game but you
never want to get off level one but then
you always aspire to beat the game you
can't beat the game if you stay on level
one
also chicken wing
so we're switching to Cleveland
yes from awesomeness the awesomeness yes
yeah okay Murr are you a gamer world
renowned yeah me do it let me do it let
me do it try for yes that's what he goes
by No
like Zelda where link starts out in
Kokura forks he has no idea what's going
on in the world when you leave your
local area you find out the dangers that
are there and the different cultures
that you meet when you journey to
different towns there's no different
from that one you join it to a different
state you meet the different type of
gamers there the different levels of
competition
gaming has literally become my life a
lot of people would say grow up and get
a life and I'm like I am grown and this
is my life what do you want me to do so
you know some people look down at it but
they don't understand you know they
don't know anything about me what I've
been through where I came from when
things got hard I stay that in a run so
you know I stick by you know what you
know I'm about and what I grew up on
video games that's my life this is what
I live
you